Tom Verducci the great baseball writer
from Sports Illustrated also it works
for the MLB Network and Fox he's in
Arizona with the Dodgers Tom is this the
day that Bryce Harper finally signs this
is the week Dan it could be the day I
get the sense that it might not be but I
do think Bryce Harper wants to get
himself in camp and not too late and I
think we're at the end game let's put it
that way I think it's a matter of days I
was wondering in Bob Nightingale said
this to us what six weeks ago he said no
it's a done deal he's going to
Philadelphia
I got the feeling Scott Boras Bryce
Harper's agent got the deal or at least
got a number that he could go and shop
around and he's been shopping for quite
some time but he's coming back to what
would be maybe close to the original
deal what do you think of that process I
do think there's a little bit of truth
of that listen we knew where the market
started when the Nationals made that
offer at the end of the season 300 over
ten years right I mean there was a lot
of deferred money in that so it wasn't a
true 300 present-day value but you got a
sense of where it was going to go I
always thought the idea someone was
going to sign him for a short-term
contract for a high AAV was ludicrous
embrace and Scott Boras basically have
really scheduled this since the time he
was 16 years old in terms of hitting
free agency at 26 right and I think I do
think that a little bit of filly bidding
against himself a little bit of that JD
Martinez in Boston last year mmm and
getting it to campus really the soft
deadline to get it finally done I think
what's happening here if Scott wants to
make sure he gets this above the 325
that Stanton got from the Marlins that's
the largest contract ever given out in
baseball history I'm sure he'd love to
break that I'm not sure if
Philadelphia's going to get there but
there does come a point where you say a
310 or 315 it's not your bad camp if you
were the commissioner you could place
Bryce Harper in a place for the good of
the game where would you place him I
would put him in LA or New York Dodgers
or the Yankees I mean I just saw
something where he was rated there was a
sport marketing company it rated him too
13th most marketable athlete in the
world our jet is the only baseball
player ahead of him on that list and
there is something about Bryce Harper I
think that's appealing the matter what
market he plays in but why not maximize
that kind of exposure
I mean Dan you know it's rare that you
get a baseball player like Bryce well it
can walk down the street of virtually
any city of this country and people know
who he is
I think Aaron judges that way and I
think Bryce is that way and that may be
it you know I love Mike Trout I think he
can get away pretty anonymously with
walking down most streets in this
country Bryce's got that in fact there's
no question so to answer your question I
built big market are the Padres sneaky
go market size are they they all in on
Manny Machado yeah they all are they
like him you know I think it makes sense
then they have the number one farm
system at baseball the owner there Ron
Fowler has had the team for six years
he is yet to field a winning team he is
yet to have any position players start
the all-star game or get an MVP vote or
get a sihyoung vote basically there is
they haven't been a relevant team and I
think there's a point where you have to
go listen we're ready to win close to
being ready to win making a commitment
to someone like Machado makes a lot of
sense good position player is mostly
pitching that's coming up but I do think
it's a situation where you're going to
sign a guy for eight to nine years your
window is right around the corner don't
wait till the window opens up make sure
you can get the window open a little
sooner by getting someone like Machado
they've met him twice
you know AJ Prowler the general manager
flew from the West Coast and Miami now
if you know AJ it's not really a big
deal because he never sleeps and he has
more frequent flyer miles than anybody I
know it's the way he runs but when you
had that second visit person-to-person
fly cross-country and sit down at with
banning Miami that told me they're very
serious you're there with the Dodgers in
spring training what's the biggest
question that has to be answered with
this team there's not a whole lot of
questions actually I thought the [ __ ]
signing really completed the same ban I
think on paper they're the best team in
the National League and I don't say that
because they went you know to the World
Series two years in a row they are
incredibly deep my ass you know
nitpick anything I would say Corey
Seager's health I mean we see him back
he's in uniform all right he's back he's
playing he's Corey Seager but that's two
major surgeries he had the Tommy John
surgery on the throwing arm and the hip
surgery as well I just got a feeling you
got to give this guy time I'm talking
about half of a season then even if he's
out there I don't think he's gonna be an
impact player right away but so far at
least is saying the signs are good he's
on track to be there opening day but man
I think this is a team that has more
depth than anybody else they can
basically lose anybody on their roster
and cover for it really well and is that
why they weren't involved in the Machado
or Bryce Harper sweepstakes yes you know
you look since Andrew Friedman got that
team and you know he has got all in on
depth more so than at the top of the
roster
he's not anybody who believes in the
so-called stars and scrubs kind of setup
where you spend a lot of money top of
your roster and you kind of piece
together the back half of it in the last
four years he's used 52 players at least
52 players every year I mean it's just
incredible what they go through and I
think what you're looking at now he
hasn't stepped out really I think the
other than the Kershaw extension Janssen
contract was the most money he spent so
in terms of going out and getting big
free agents you know he hasn't been in
that 100 million-dollar 200
million-dollar range I just don't
believe he believes in that and their
farm system is so good that they can
play this depth game so yeah I mean
listen look at their attendance ood then
they're you know six years in a row
they've won that division droid three
million not a crying need to go out
there and get a superstar name if we
talk in a week rice Harper is where and
Manny Machado is where I think Brice is
until adelphia and I have not ruled out
the Yankees on Machado you know I think
if Manny wants to take a lesser contract
I believe his heart is in New York and
the Yankees I think are playing it
smartly to get him on their terms but I
do think the Mucky in Chicago with the
white sox or san diego is gonna be so
good I'm gonna put him in San Diego
because I think when push comes to shove
most of these guys are gonna sign for
the money
any chance Tim Tebow star
the season in the majors with the
medicine no there's no chance he starts
the season with the Mets I think he's
gonna be there before the end of the
year the only thing yeah I don't know if
you've seen the video of him Kevin I
haven't been a Mets cap yet it looks
like he's even stronger and bigger this
year to me he's gone back to looking
like a football player at playing
baseball I'm not sure that's a good
thing we know he's like the world's
hardest worker I thought he looked a
little better in terms of athleticism
and smoothness as a baseball player last
year and this year I think he has to be
careful without big and he actually get
Andy's gonna get married so he's gonna
let himself go so Tom thank you I
appreciate your time Tom Verducci senior
baseball writer at Sports Illustrated
and also contributes to Fox and the MLB
Network there for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]